je vais vous poser la question qui tue
maintenant peggy bouchet est ce qu'on
peut faire la lumière de la question qui
tue sexuellement ça se passe et comment
sur ce bateau c'est difficile
sérieusement ça vous a manqué non je
crois que quand on fait beaucoup
d'efforts comme ça comme ça et puis non
on ne pense pas trop non mais c'est pas
une partie de rigolade quaife indiqué
l'ars
donc c'est 4 de dire c'est de la galère
tous les jours c'est des peurs ses des
souffrances est bon tout ça on n'a pas
le temps passer au reste on met la
lumière ça pouvait appeler dépenser
moi alors regardez moi la question mais
moi je vois le pognon l'arrivée au
sérieux alors aujourd'hui il est dans
une banque en suisse gardé par la
justice me giraud qui aura lieu est ce
que vous aviez eu à choisir donc entre
d'une part vivre en arabie saoudite
cloîtré avec vos enfants ou quitter
l'arabie saoudite et vivre sans vos
enfants est-ce que des fois vous vous
dites pas j'aurais mieux fait de rester
en arabie saoudite parce que je serai
toujours avec mes enfants je me dis ça
tous les matins je vous dis ça tous les
matins et tous les matins quand je parle
à mes enfants je leur demande de me
pardonner d'avoir
décidé de partir parce que je ne pouvais
plus être une bonne mère où je pensais
qu'à la fin je veux devenir une mère
folle et mais je sais aujourd'hui ma
force de résistance était telle que
j'aurais pu rester et d'ailleurs mon
fils aîné me dit jusqu'à présent maman
tu es parti trop tôt bienvenue non
est-ce que vous avez jamais regretté
cette opération jamais jamais non non je
suis très heureuse et pour rien au monde
je me souviens quand je suis rentrée à
la clinique
je me suis dit mais tu es sûre qu'est ce
que c'est en train de faire parce qu'il
fallait vraiment faire confiance
cette fois ci au médecin parce que le
fait que je fasse un métier public et
bon c'était c'était assez dangereux
quand même et j'ai eu confuse j'ai eu la
foi comme je lé souvent dans ma vie et
je me suis dit j'y vais je pense que
c'est quelque chose de bien pour moi
bravo à lui
il
répondez moi
sauf qu'à l'époque mon père était donc
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports et
dans le cadre donc de sens de son action
il devait venir sur le campus de
nanterre où moi j'étais étudiante pour
inaugurer et la piscine de nanterre et
et à l'époque donc il y avait comme une
sorte d'effervescence qui commençait sur
le campus c'était en janvier et les
événements allaient se passer en mai et
donc à l'époque c'était pas plus d'une
quarantaine à peu près d'étudiants mais
qui commence est quand même à faire un
peu de grabuge et à leur tête il y avait
un homme un garçon dont qui s'appelait
daniel cohn bendit et lorsque mon père
est arrivé pour inaugurer la trentaine
d'étudiants l'attendait et à ce moment
là ils ont commencé à dire à mon père
qu'est ce que vous faites vous pour les
problèmes sexuels des jeunes étudiants
et mon père leur a répondu je viens
inauguré des piscines et puis toi qui
m'a posé la question si tu as un
problème sexuel plonge donc la tête la
première tu verras ça résout déjà pas
mal de temps
et puis à l'époque donc comme mon père
était ministre il était suivi par
pléthore de personnes dont un préfet de
police et le préfet de police trouvant
que ce jeune homme s'était mal adressée
à mon père à demander comme ils étaient
de nationalité étrangère qu'il soit
expulsé et mon père a dit à ce moment là
non je suis désolé si on doit expulser
quelqu'un on excuse pour le des raisons
valables mais c'est tout de même pas
parce qu'il m'a posé cette question là
qu'il doit être expulsés du territoire
français
ce qui me paraît d'ailleurs très normal
est censé comme réponse et puis les
événements sont arrivés de 68 et là vous
savez les gens commencent à perdre la
boule on savait plus très bien où on en
était chocolat des journaux notamment un
journal qui heureusement n'existe plus
aujourd'hui et qui étaient orduriers et
qui a commencé à dire
il semble que il paraît que on croit que
mais qui n'affirme est jamais ce garçon
qui s'appelle cohn bendit n'a pas été
expulsé de france parce qu'il a été
protégé par le ministre parce que il
avait il a fait rester là or je n'ai
jamais rencontré cohn bendit qu'il a
d'ailleurs écrit lui-même dans un de ces
dans un bouquin je crois et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui si je le vois dans la rue
eh bien moi je le reconnaîtrai parce que
je sais la tête qu'il a je le vois des
émissions de télé à etc
mais lui et je crois incapable de dire
quelle est la couleur de mes yeux et je
finit d'ailleurs par lui regretter parce
que je me dis que tant qu'à faire quand
vous prêtez ac est une histoire autant
connaître vraiment la personne avec
laquelle justement voudrait bien on
rallume la lumière merci
non gérables d'un sérieux vous m'arriver
jamais non je pensais pas non à oui
c'est un principe parce que sa femme
c'est pratique c'est ça ça représente
rien pour moi alors on dit oui mais pour
faire plaisir à la femme qu'on aime si
mathilde vous le demande
ma vie mais je lui ferais plaisir mais
je ne ferai pas plaisir à moi donc un
haut rhin qui sera lésé dans les docks
ce que j l'amour c'est regarder la
télévision dans le même sens donc c'est
définitif bah ouais je crois je crois
oui bon on rallume servent ses tresses
et arrive alors et senna fait flasher
passé le fait pas cela rend pas triste
mathilde je chie mais enfin bon il me
connaît mathilde seigner
bien elle est pas là je sais qu'elle
n'est pas l'accord alors jamais en fait
vous êtes géré assez d'origine
piémontaise en fait transfrontalier
transalpin dix ans et on comprend mieux
votre personnage quand on sait ça en
fait parce que vous avez un côté
commedia dell arte est d'ailleurs votre
premier rôle à lyon s'était amusé dans
une pièce en général vous étiez un valet
de comédie quoi oui c'était celle
tartuffe way et donc que vous avez ce
côté commedia dell'arte de trouver comme
sadeghi milk des phrases clés en fait on
business et ça en fait le malg imx et
installe toujours un personnage
ouais ça sale sale situe immédiatement
donc c'est vrai que j'ai toujours eu ce
tarif mais si ça maintenant maintenant
j'ai compris ça je vous comprends mais
je commence à comprendre le personnage
gilbert collard quoi est ce que quand
vous dites gilbert collard qu'on vous
dit
quand vous dites gilbert collard quand
vous dis une fois plus rien on ne m'aime
pas et je le sais est ce que finalement
votre problème dans la vie ça serait pas
d'être aimée tout simplement je crois
que le problème de tous les êtres
humains c'est de n'être pas assez aimée
oui oui oui je le confesse volontiers
donc c'est pour ça vous êtes comme ça
peut-être peut-être vous êtes sincère là
tout à fait dit la vérité là on rallume
serge
patrick poivre d'arvor
que répondez vous à ceux qui disent qu à
votre place
aux usa le présentateur du journal
télévisé aurait déjà démissionné
moi j'ai démissionné j'ai démissionné
mes patrons n'ont pas voulu que je parte
mais j'ai proposé ma démission
j'ai payé ma rédemption je pense l'avoir
connu dans les deux affaires auxquelles
vous avez fait allusion
et puis voilà et je pense que les gens
qu'on payait bas ils ont le droit à une
nouvelle chance et donc ça me paraît pas
absurde très bien rallume merci
c'est la question qui tue francis huster
est pas la question qui fâche comme
disent certains copieurs c'est au sujet
des j'adore la vie christiane à vous a
dit quoi franchement elle vous a dit
quand elle a vu le spectacle
elle vous a dit quoi je suis tu es
complètement con elle avait vu un
festival ça elle avait trouvé ça
formidable comme un crétin j'ai fait
trois erreurs le soir de la générale y
avait un micro avec une réverbération
dans la sage d'épouvantables on a
l'impression de parler devant derrière
en plus ça m'avait dit de me méfier de
tous les sketches de paysans j'en ai
trois ou quatre toiser pas mal oui jouer
de petites bio et donc ça alors voilà au
bout de deux ans on en a marre et puis
la troisième chose c'est
qu'effectivement j'aurais peut-être dû
commencer la trilogie avec la peste ou
du diesel a trouvé que j'avais des
couilles d'arrêter mais elle n'était pas
très chaude pour le spectacle ah non non
non elle le trouvait travail c'était de
la folie très bien trop risqué donc elle
vous aime on rallume missionnaire
francis huster bien racontée est un
succès les charrues la distribution dans
la tente d'ailleurs vous pouvez lui dire
un questionnaire on vous attend il
paraît qu'elle a un petit peu peur de
moi alors je vous le dit christiana chez
un mec vachement sympa ivana trump
questions importantes si demain matin
donald trump revenait vers vous et vous
proposer de reprendre la vie de famille
avec vos enfants
il y en oublie tout on se remet ensemble
tous et on reprend une vie normale tu me
pardonnes excuse moi est ce que vous
seriez d'accord est ce que vous lui
diriez oui ou non à ce stade je dirais
non
si j'en suis vraiment convaincu d'abord
parce que je suis amoureuse d'un autre
homme
et puis il ya tellement de mal qui a été
fait bon bien sûr je suis remonté et
maintenant les enfants ou réussir à
atteindre un stade de paix paisible et
moi je veux continuer avec ma vie et
puis donald a des intérêts guides sont
différents à manger des intérêts
différence passe beaucoup de temps en
europe
de ma vie je fais des choses différentes
et lui il continue à travailler
travailler travailler ces milliards et
c'est pas fait pour moi ce n'est plus
fait pour nos groupes aucun espoir on
allume un bon juif même si votre père
est juif et votre mère l'est pas en tant
que juif en portant un patronyme juifs
vous retrouvez occident ça ne s'est
jamais embêté et moi sincèrement de dd
sa durée de trois ans je n'ai jamais
ressenti le moindre sentiment de ce
genre dans un moment politique est
d'ailleurs aucun des membres des deux
sets
l'association d'étudiants qui ont fait
de la politique par la suite ne sait par
exemple retrouver au front national vous
avez cité des noms tout à l'heure il y
en a d'autres
ils sont tous dans des formations
politiques de la droite républicaine ou
qu'un est allé au front national et moi
je n'ai jamais à cette époque ressenti
le moindre racisme
d'abord c'était pas du tout le sujet à
l'époque c'était effectivement le
communisme la guerre du vietnam les
événements de mai 68
donc c'était pas du tout le sujet et je
n'ai jamais ressenti cela d'ailleurs si
je l'avais ressenti évidemment j'aurais
pas pu y rester
non non c'est pas ça c'était pas ça du
tout l'occident c'est vraiment un
mouvement d'étudiants qui se défendent
est dans un univers pas très simple ok
j'ai jamais eue sera terrible
alors la mac
est ce que en vous voyant être devenu le
chantre du capital est ce que vous
croyez pas que votre père vous savez
c'est un ancien communiste
ils ont fait aussi beaucoup de chemin
alors j'ai poursuivi le chemin qu'il
avait entamée si je puis dire j'étais
allé très loin parce que quand même lui
peut être communiste et avoir été déçu
par par le stalinisme qui peut avoir été
des hommes par par budapest il peut
avoir été déçu par beaucoup de choses
comme ça
mais malgré tout il est quand même là un
idéal au départ près des halles
communiste le fait que son fils soit
devenu le chantre du nouveau capitalisme
s'allonge pas de dormir non mais vous
voyez qu'en dit libéral de gauche c'est
assez utile parce que j'espère que lui
comprend gauche et que les gens avec
lesquels je travaille comprennent
libéral ouais très bien à lui vous savez
que jacques chirac est malade c'est pour
ça qu'il a grossi dernièrement c'est
pour ça qu'après des vacances tout le
monde l'a trouvé un pompier un petit peu
enflée du visage vous apprenez donc les
cancéreux qui prend de la cortisone
comme le président pompidou que ce
traitement occasionne un comportement
encore pire que celui qu'il a en ce
moment non vous faites quoi tient à rien
je voterai pas pour lui la prochaine
fois mais vous le dit pas mais non on
rallume baril maintenant sérieusement
est-ce que vous avez un mime et niekro
preuve que jean-pierre mairie aurait pu
être assassiné
ou est ce que c'est une vous dites il
aurait pu être assassiné ou ce que vous
avez un début de quelque chose vous
savez on n'a pas besoin d'eux
forcément d'une preuve là la preuve la
reine de la preuve c'est l'aveu de la
propre personne
mais on a des indices graves et
concordants et vous savez et dernier le
système judiciaire français par exemple
les assises il n'y a pas besoin de
preuve il suffit que les gens sont
convaincus
il suffit que les personnes qui sont
derrière qui vont juger
il suffit qu'ils aient assez d'éléments
pour qu'ils soient convaincus est qu'il
donne vingt ans de prison à la personne
qui est qu'ils ont à juger enrhume jean
claude gayssot donc excusé pas le
sentiment que vous vivez une aventure
personnelle payer votre compte de fait
est que finalement vous allez un petit
peu oublié que j'étais ouvrier que
j'avais était de l'autre côté
non je n'ai rien oublié et
et je peux vous dire que quand on a été
non seulement pauvre comme je l'étais
mais un militant un militant pour la
justice militant contre les privilèges
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs pas
simplement de la fortune mais aussi du
pouvoir et du savoir
eh bien ça s'oublie pas et quand ils
vous arrivent c'est un aspect
exceptionnel devons trouver ministre
vous essayez de
à ce moment là votre petite échelle de
continuer à à ne pas oublier ce que vous
avez été ce que sont des millions 10
millions dont merci aux remerciements
henri d'orléans croyez-vous après avoir
entendu tout ça que la famille d'orléans
puisse encore régné sur la france
ça ne dépend que des français on rallume
alors jean yanne nous à lui faire de la
radio vous avez voulu faire de la télé
vous avez voulu réaliser des films j'ai
voulu faire des affaires d'une société
de tournage de films français aux états
unis et chine américain en france
vous avez voulu faire de la décoration
d'hôtel mais si vous aviez choisi d'être
que acteurs français pas qu'aujourd'hui
vous seriez un des premiers acteurs du
monde pas seulement acteur parce que
c'est pas moi qui ai choisi des
tracteurs s'étaient pas non c'était pas
mon truc moi je suis je voulais faire
partie du spectacle et surtout je
voulais écrire des choses comme quand
des fois on demande on dit mais qu'est
ce que vous regrettez le plus chez lui
dire je regrette simplement que pendant
des années on mais on ne met pas demandé
d'écrire les dialogues parce que j'étais
persuadé que je serai un bon dialoguiste
michel hecart c'est sûr ils gardent le
disais les cadets tu devrais cours
didier rey mais les gens voulaient pas
mais je dis ça sans aigreur puisque j'ai
fait d'autres choses plus lucratives
mais pour moi acteurs c'est pas le truc
évidemment qui me passionne le plus
et si c'était à refaire vous referiez la
même chose et je t'ai si c'était à
refaire je referais la même chose dans
les grandes ligues c'est dire que je met
par exemple je ferai beaucoup plus de
choses dans la décoration beaucoup plus
chaud dans l'urbain à un coût beaucoup
plus de choses dans les choses comme ça
à paraître lundi
trop dans la musique j'ai pas assez bien
tu crois c'est vrai j'aurais adoré
travailler avec avec des urbanistes
j'aurais aimé partie du projet brasilia
tout ce facteur qua non pas tous aux
facteurs mais on est toujours acteur de
quelque chose dans une société qui nous
entoure
on a les mains
alors nos montebourg est-ce que vous
pensez pas que vous seriez quand même
plus crédible si vous vous occupiez
parallèlement d affaire de la mnef et
pas seulement de chirac mais aussi de
monsieur le guen de monsieur cambadélis
de monsieur dominique strauss kahn je
vais vous dire que le parti socialiste
en est occupé ouais et à empêcher toute
candidature de cela et que par ailleurs
le parti socialiste avait demandé à
l'époque le départ d'un certain nombre
de ceux qui étaient mis en difficulté
donc je suis heureux de voir que mon
parti faites un effort dans ce stress
penser que le parti socialiste n'a pas
besoin d'arnaud montebourg mais
seulement le rpr qui en a besoin
ça je ne sais pas qui est une question
différente et compliqué mais à une main
jean marie messier questions simples
quoi que vous disiez est ce que vous
pensez sérieusement qu alain de greef
est encore l'homme de la situation en
tant que directeur des programmes de
canal plus
ce que je crois c'est que alain de greef
et un homme de programme remarquable par
seulement derrière pour les programmes
de canal+ mais pour l'ensemble des
chaînes thématiques et des différentes
offres de canal est l autre ambition
pour lui le c'est pas mon ambition pour
lui c'est le choix qu'il doit faire et
un truc qui est vrai c'est que on entend
beaucoup de critiques sur npa en disant
mais c'est dépassé ça a changé et c'est
il faut d'abord moi je suis pas
nostalgique
gildas de caunes c'était génial du jeu
on s'est pas mal du tout et il ya un
truc qui est simple canal ça toujours
été à la pointe de l'innovation
on le doit de greffe et de greffe encore
énormément de choses à portet canal n'y
pas de doute là dessus
[Musique]
jean glavany
c'est très simple on se souvient n'en
profite pas à laurent parce qu'il fait
nuit on se souvient du nuage de
tchernobyl qui s'était arrêté à la
frontière franco allemande
alors concernant la sphère de la vache
folle est ce qu aurait des choses qu'on
ne sait pas nous français oui oui mais
c'est pas parce que vous voulez cacher
on le sait pas parce que vous le savez
pas non plus mais c'est pas si je
laissais pas non plus énergiques ne le
savent pas non plus il n'ya pas des
choses que vous savez aujourd'hui je
vois rien des choses gran on dit vaut
mieux pas le dire aux gens parce que non
ça va être la psychose nationale rien
c'est sûr et certain
donc vous dites y'a rien français que
vous ne sachiez pas sur cette affaire
non vraiment franchement rien tu as bien
on rallume
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors eric cantona cette décision ne pas
vous faire jouer en équipe de france en
98 qui est pas été du tout comprise par
les par les français parce que tout le
monde attendait évidemment vous soyez
dans l'équipe de france est-ce que vous
en voulez aimé jacquet est ce que vous
avez de la haine parce que finalement
votre rêve s'est envolé ce jour là non à
un moment donné j'ai eu de la haine bien
sûr j'aime ou pas de la haine mais bon
oui j'aurais préféré jouer mais
aujourd'hui je suis innocent j'ai plus
du tournant à gérer et puis ce qui s'est
passé c'est très bien peut-être que si
j'avais joué se serait pas passé comme
ça qu'est ce que si j'avais joué se
serait passé comme ça ou peut-être ça ne
sera jamais et puis ses mixes se soit
passé comme ça ne vous ai pas le
sentiment d'être orphelin de cette
victoire d'une certaine façon j'ai vécu
les des trucs extraordinaires des
grandes des grandes joies et des grandes
déceptions et ça fait partie des grandes
déceptions et ça fait partie de la vie
ça fait partie des choses qui nous font
avancer
on rallume donc ce que vous dites
monseigneur di falco ce soir c'est que
un catholique peut très bien utiliser un
préservatif et tout le monde puisque des
préservatifs c'est pas condamnée par le
vatican
à partir du moment vous ne parvenez pas
à vivre l'idéal de fidélité par exemple
et que vous avez des relations sexuelles
bien vous ne pourront peut pas prendre
de risque d'être soit criminel soit
suicidaire il faut utiliser le
préservatif
je croyais temps des questions de bon
sens non mais attendez ça c'est la
position de monseigneur di falco qui est
à passer la position où la position du
pape c'est la position explique les de
façon claire de l'église bien à lui
[Musique]
donc hervé bourges pour quelles raisons
pour quelle raison le csa a accordé à
tf1 qui est déjà riche à milliards
deux minutes de plus de pub par heure
pour quelle raison puis écoutez là de la
décision qui a été prise à l'époque est
une décision juridique parce que c'était
le droit commun c'est tout voilà c'est
pour quelle raison de faire ce cadeau
était le cadeau c'est vous qui le dites
moi j'ai rien d'autre à cantonner cette
chaîne commerciale deux minutes de plus
de plus un cadeau qu'on lui fait quand
même moi j'ai rien d'autre alors je vous
pose est maintenant une dernière
question est-ce que vous éteignez la
lumière
question simple gilles ménage question
très simple vous êtes un ou services de
l'état avaient fait des narbonnais
étaient dans les cabinets préfectoraux
est ce que finalement maintenant avec le
recul puisque publier des livres pour en
parler
est ce que vous regrettez pas excusé pas
un peu honte d'avoir fait tout ça
évidemment de nombreux jeux pan os
déjà on non je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que d'abord je qualifie pas comme
vous les qualifiés est ce que je peux
dire c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'une
décision a été prise
j'ai toujours fait un papier écrit j'ai
toujours demandé d instruction je suis
instructions je ne pense vraiment pas
avoir ont franchi la ligne jaune
enfin je veux pas je veux pas vous
chargez m'enfin papon aussi dit moi je
ne faisait qu'obéir aux ordres
quand on est fonctionnaire au départ
mais quand on est fonctionnaire on peut
le dire j'ai obéi aux ordres il bien non
il ya des fois il faut savoir désobéir
c'est ce que tout le monde a dit à
papandréou vous auriez dû désobéi on
n'était pas du tout dans cette
configuration là je voulais la situation
était moins grave
bon lorsque ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est le fond de ma réponse un
fonctionnaire si vous voulez ne peut pas
prendre l'initiative en tout cas moi
c'est ma philosophie
sans être totalement en harmonie avec le
pouvoir politique
or il se trouve que dans son pays dans
ce pays à taden politique parce que ça
les arrange parce qu'ils ont des soucis
de carrière sont parfois amnésique
parfois renégats et ça devient un peu
facile de dire ben voilà nous
on n'était pas au courant on savait pas
de taper le lampiste alors vous dites
non moi j'ai pas
après tout je trouve que j'ai eu
beaucoup de satisfactions à faire ce
métier il ya depuis quelques années
c'est vrai beaucoup d'inconvénients
je pense que dans la vie il faut savoir
accepter les inconvénients t davantage
bien à lui merci bien là maintenant chez
vous vous éteignez la lumière et je
réponds alors en as t'il pas la télé
c'est un mec qui me dit quand on fait la
question qui tue on éteint la lumière
mais ce qu'on doit éteindre la télé non
on éteint que la lumière laurent est ici
aussi
voilà c'est chaud la conception nouis
fernandez serez-vous encore entraîneur
du psg la saison prochaine
jusqu'à preuve du contraire oui même si
vous perdez tous les matches qui
viennent là je ne souhaite pas perdre et
je pense qu'on ne perdra pas tous les
matches qui restent très on va en gagner
on va remonter on va on va se situer
dans une position qui sera un peu plus
honorable pour le paris saint germain et
pour tous ceux qui aiment le paillis
maman merci on rallume
robert louis dreyfus alors dans cette
affaire est ce que finalement vous ai
pas le sentiment d'être un peu un gosse
de riche qui s'est fait plumer par l'om
n'embauchent que gosse de riche je
l'étais montfa sais pas j'ai jamais mes
parents m'ont jamais d'argent alors donc
j'ai pas de problème là dessus de cette
fumée non parce qu'il ya des ya tout de
même une valeur et puis un plaisir donc
ça vaut le plaisir
vous regrettez pas non pas du tout
c'était à refaire je ferais tu ferais
peut-être moins d'erreurs parce que
j'aurais appris quelque chose
ouais bon allez
[Applaudissements]
didier deschamps eu concevez jouer avec
la juge vous avez été entendu par un
juge d'instruction turinois pour des
problèmes de busage de dopage maison de
créatine
qu'en est il exactement j'ai été
confrontée trois fois oui c'est vrai à
un juge d'instruction qui avant même de
poser des questions étaient persuadés
que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilise l epo
donc c'est très difficile de
de faire face à un tel personnage la
créatine aussi c'est vrai qu'elle est
utilisée elle autorisée dans ces pays
certains pays dans notre nom j'en ai
pris pendant une certaine période après
j'ai arrêté je pense pas que ce soit un
produit nocif même si certains
spécialistes se le dise mais le dopage
en règle générale et je pense qu' il y
en a dans le sport dans le football j'ai
pas été confronté parce que je pense
sincèrement je vois pas l'utilité
je crois pas que le dopage quand même
produit peut d'un
la joueur bidon de faire un super joueur
mais ça jamais fait tirer dans les
lucarnes je vois pas trop l'utilité ça
peut faire courir plus vite ça peut être
plus résistants mais il ya le ballon et
le balancer les pieds il faut savoir le
diriger donc des matchs très souvent
même temps la répétition évidemment
qu'on a des aides
il vaut pharmaceutiques pour aider à
récupérer mais ce juge là est partie du
principe moi c'est ce qui m'a dit enfin
d'interrogatoire il me dit je voudrais
arriver à faire une loi que le
footballeur ci prend un produit une
vitamine c peut importe où on est
enrhumé ou qui prend quelque chose la
semaine à voir le match il ne puisse pas
jouer un match il y aurait plus beaucoup
de football à la télé bien merci de
votre sincérité mais laissons la
question
[Musique]
sérieusement est-ce que vous pensez que
en étant parti dans les conditions qu'on
connaît en revenant en vous faisant
élire
est-ce que vous pensez que vous aidez la
politique
en agissant de la sorte mais moi je je
ne cherche pas à aider la politique je
cherche à aider la ville dans laquelle
je travaille depuis tant d'années a
progressé à aller de l'avant
j'essaye d'aider les levalloisiens moi
j'ai fais de la politique pour aider les
autres pour servir uniquement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
besoin de faire la politique
je suis né dans une famille où on avait
tout ce qu'il fallait
il y avait une affaire il y avait tout
ce qu'il fallait je n'avais vraiment pas
besoin de politiques pour gagner de
l'argent comme certains voudraient le
laisser dire blessés entendre moi j'ai
fait de la politique vraiment par
conviction et je continue à faire de la
politique aujourd'hui si je vous dévouez
finalement pour levallois s'est pas
votre intérêt personnel c'est pour la
ville assad et ça l'a toujours été et ça
continuera à l'être et mon épouse aussi
et votre action votre tour votre
élection pour l'image de la politique
des hommes politiques
pensez que c'est bénéfique vous savez je
sais pas si l'image des hommes
politiques est aussi bénéfique pour moi
en tout cas je me rends je me rends
compte d'une chose c'est que sans
investiture je suis élu d'autres avec
les investitures de tous les partis ne
sont pas élus très bien on rallume
michel rocard eux
je n'ai jamais été président si c'était
à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil une seule chose
mettre mon mandat en balance sur un
mauvais résultat aux élections
européennes ouais pour me faire jeter
sur hazard par mauvaise foi et raté par
l'investiture
c'est ma faute technique vous avez perdu
les européennes vous n'auriez pas dû
partir finalement vous dois dû rester
oui vous auriez rêvé un an et demi avant
reprocher à laurent fabius de ne l'avoir
pas fait ce que tous les grands
dirigeants européens font s'ils ont
perdu on s'en va je fais partie de cette
race est aussi ma dignité
je suis partie sur une faute tactique
mais au moins dans la dignité
alors merci est ce que vous croyez pas
ivan levaï quand même que la promiscuité
des grands c'est à dire la fréquentation
que vous aviez de mitterrand vous a
amené certaines fois avoir un jugement
mois objectif que celui qu'on était en
droit d'attendre de quelqu'un d'aussi
écouté que vous non moi j'ai pas peur de
la connivence des journalistes et des
hommes politiques
il ya une chose que je redoute c'est la
malhonnêteté
or il ya des hommes politiques qui sont
malhonnêtes avec des journalistes et des
journalistes qui sont malhonnêtes avec
des hommes politiques c'est tout chacun
chez soi lui il est élu vous vous ne
l'êtes pas et
on ne se doit rien moi je ne dois rien
invité à la che comme ça tout ça vous ne
venez pas être plus sympas avec
mitterrand que si vous n'aviez pas été
invité non ça permet de voir ce qu'il y
a ceux qui demeurent d'humanité vrai
chez les hommes que vous rencontrez et
je fume
est ce que vous étiez au courant de
l'existence de ari boulogne que nous
avons reçu ici
le fils d'alain delon et de nico qui est
né en 68 et gentil à la période où vous
avez rencontré de long est ce que vous
connaissiez sur l'existence oui avant
que quand j'ai rencontré alain oui c'est
très bien son existence puisqu'il
n'était pas son fils et qu'elle s'est
pointé au studio en disant voilà ton
fils oui mais vous pensez que c'est
passé par oui ou par non nous l'énoncé
m'a pas vu auparavant c'est vous dites
donc vous êtes au courant de l'existence
d'un lit très bien mais vous dites ce
n'est pas le fils d'alain delon
voilà je dis ce qui était vrai c'était
pas maintenant si vous pouvez prouver le
contraire maintenant je pouvais rien du
tout je me demande pourquoi vous l'aimez
bien j'ai de la tendresse pour lui une
certaine compassion pour ce que la vie
qu'il a eue oui j'ai des villes tout
petit point
et je ne pense pas sur le fils d'alain
delon mais attendez j'étais pas là ce
moment là ce soir là non non avant
primes
jean christophe mitterrand
vous avez quoi à dire votre père ce soir
offre
que je pense beaucoup à lui que je laime
et que je regrette qu'on soit quand
j'étais jeune un peu raté merci aura lui
aux méthodes eric zemmour
comment vous l'auteur des rats de garde
avec patrick poivre d'arvor est un
ouvrage sur la presse people et les
paparazzi comment vous pouvez dans votre
bouquin parler du suicide de laurence la
fille aînée des chirac qui est
anorexique et qui est une sorte d'
enfant caché du couple est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est bien pour le suicide
de laurence bernadette elle-même en
parle donc sa mère et deuxièmement je
faisais un portrait de chirac ce n'est
pas un livre théorique politique
c'était un portrait de l'homme je
voulais faire un roman une espèce de
roman vrai de jacques chirac comme un
personnage romanesque et donc j'avais
besoin de montrer
toutes les facettes de ce type et
justement pour expliquer ce que vous
avez remarqué tout à l'heure c'est à
dire qu'il sait que le bonheur n'existe
pas et que c'est un type profondément
malheureux je pense que le drame que vit
sa fille
fais partie de ceux de ce malheur profit
vous savez je raconte aussi une scène
quand pasqua
vous savez quand elle se suicide elle
est à l'hôpital et le premier le premier
à venir
c'est pasqua alors qu'ils sont en guerre
politique et que les chinois sont
entaillés lors de ce moment voilà les
chercheurs thaïlandais qui reprennent
l'avion et les passe quoi bon les veillé
toute la nuit et quand pasqua sort de
l'hôpital
pasqua dit
vraiment on peut rapprocher ce qu'on
veut à chirac mais il porte sa croix
il sait que sa fille est malade parce
qu'il a fait de la politique on rallume
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que ce
que vous racontez est vrai je crois
vraiment que ce que raconte le
gouvernement américain il faut c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que je crois que
ce que j'ai analysé et certainement
extrêmement proche de la vérité morale m
lucien aimé blanc vous affirmez dans
votre livre
robert broussard ne pouvait pas être
témoin de la fusillade et des
circonstances qui l'ont provoqué car il
était à ce moment précis assis à côté de
moi dans sa voiture garée à 50 mètres de
là est hors de vue de la scène grâce à
ben non je confirme complètement
nous étions dans la voiture de
commandement depuis le matin en été en
dans le périphérique un peu plus loin à
200 mètres de l'immeuble puis lorsque le
dispositif s'est mis en branle e tr 7 e
logiquement broussard qui était tout
voleur mois passagers puis avec
l'inspecteur derrière c'est cette
avancée vers la porte de clignancourt
car il avait donné des instructions pour
que la voiture de de mesrine ne dépasse
pas le feu rouge
il n'est pas hors de question d'aller
allait le suivre sur le périphérique on
savait pas où ils allaient puis
l'opération était homme était trop trop
trop aléatoires donc cette avancée sous
la rampe au niveau de la passe de signer
encore une cinquantaine cinquantaine de
mètres à peu près on voyait rien et à ce
moment là la radio
le camion a fait savoir à monsieur
broussard qu'il était en place et que la
bm de mesrine était derrière
alors il a donné l'ordre d'intervention
il a dit intervenez les gens intervenez
les gars aux allergies et les gars enfin
il a donné lors des interventions à ce
moment là les rafales ont éclaté des
rafales sèche courtes dont il venait de
sortir de la voiture et s'est précipité
sur l'apport de clients court pour
rejoindre ses effectifs et mesrine était
mort puisqu'il y avait pas ya pas eu de
riposte au coup par coup
y a pas eu de bruit de grenade puisque
vous savez qu'il avait des grenades dans
la voiture et moi je me suis vu les
suivis tout tout à fait tranquillement
je dois avouer je savais que c'était
fini je me suis pas précipité c'était
lui qui était responsable de ce
dispositif
donc ce que vous affirmez aujourd'hui
lucien aimé blanc sait que le
commissaire broussard ne peut pas savoir
si des sommations ont été faites pas
plus que moyen mesrine a essayé
d'attraper des grenades offensives qui
était à l'inter de sa portière ou sous
son siège tout ce qu'il raconte c'est
pour couvrir ces mecs là je pense parce
que écouter à un moment donné on était
dans la voiture dont il n'est pas sorti
de la voiture de commandement
et puis dans ses mémoires j'ai vu que un
moment donné au moment de la fusillade
finale il se mettait dans une
camionnette aménagée et je sais pas où
était sa camionnette aménagée mais il
aurait fallu qu'ils ont débuté il était
avec moi
point final je le confirme et puis c'est
très bien que je dis la vérité
omar haddad est ce que vous avez été
victime d'une machination
[Musique]
oui est ce que vous savez qui a monté
cette machination
non
savez pas où vous voulez pas le dire la
vérité je sais pas je veux pas causer je
peux pas faire allégeance
je peux accuser quelqu'un sans preuve
qu'on m'a fait moi je moi je le fais pas
ça vous ne rallume
bravo à issia
les chirac s'est opposé à la guerre
d'irak
il peut obtenir des américains que votre
fils ait un procès équitable
si vous l'aviez en face de vous jacques
chirac lui diriez quoi je veux lui dire
monsieur le président la vie de mon fils
il est entre vos mains et deux mois le
sauver s'ils méritent une condamnation
parce que hélas
emile et avec ce mouvement qui les
malfaiteurs s'ils méritent une
condamnation faut le faire mais pas une
condamnation à mort ni une condamnation
à vie parce que pour une mercedez sûrs
s'il arrive ça mon fils aujourd'hui et
peut arriver à quelqu'un d'autre alors
c'est pas possible de laisser les
américains faire qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent avec les enfants des autres
merci à un humain
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir si vous aviez le choix de
revenir sur terre
pour une deuxième fois est-ce que vous
choisiriez d'être le fils aîné de claude
françois
oui oui parce que définitivement je suis
je suis très fier du travail accompli et
de la mémoire et de l'empreinte qui a
laissé mon père donc
oui à la pluie
on s'appelle pas bonne mais m
pourquoi votre version ska la bonne
parce que j'avance un rebelle
ce que j'avance des preuves et ça c'est
une c'est une première tout le monde est
parti dans des théories là vous avez des
documents vous avez la cassette et
surtout j'ai pu prouver que billy sol
était celui qui disait et une fois que
vous prouver que billy sol est vraiment
le un conseil johnson vous pouvez le
croire
et puis j'ai entendu j'ai entendu cette
cassette enregistrée 71 ou clive carter
explique line and johnson a donné
l'ordre d'abattre kennedy
[Musique]
sophie thalmann franchement qu'est ce
que vous connaissez au cheval alors j'ai
j'ai personnellement un cheval s'appelle
auteuil et alors je lui murmure tous les
jours à l'oreille on allume titoff
comment va votre frère laurent c'est un
petit peu difficile sur la question là
ça va très bien il va et vient de
réaliser un making of pour le
l'enregistrement de l'album d'iam de
sortir il sait bien on a commencé
l'écriture d'un film qu'on aurait cru
qu'il va réaliser
il a réalisé un court métrage aussi et
il a pris trois kilos tout voir
différemment et même très bien
daciana golovin
êtes vous venu sur ce plateau en taxi ou
par vos propres moyens
taxi au public
est ce que vous pouvez dire ce soir que
les états unis ont envahi l'irak enfants
dans leurs interventions sur des faux
ont envahi l'irak où se tenait sur
l'argument vertu duquel il y avait des
armes de destruction massive et un
danger immédiat
l'avenant or il aurait dû savoir que les
preuves étaient trop faibles
on s'est aperçu qu'il n'y avait pas
d'armes de destruction massive si il
avait dit ils ont envahi l'irak pour se
débarrasser d'un affreux dictateur et
d'un régime sanguinaire
ça aurait été prêt mais il ne devrait
pas pu persuader le congrès américain
est clair n'aurait pas pu persuader le
parlement britannique
talleyrand guerre pour mettre fin à
cette dictature
peut-être qu'à l'avenir et dans l'avenir
des nations unies et des états unis nous
sommes prêts à mettre fin aux dictatures
simplement parce que les sanguinaires et
affreuse mais a pour l'instant non
peut-être que le jour viendra et en tout
cas c'est le souhait que je forme aura
les mains
patrick peloux si la canicule frappe à
nouveau la france cet été
les hôpitaux peuvent ils faire face si
c'était maintenant non je le dis avec
d'autant plus d'assurance que ça a été
même reconnu par le ministre de la santé
actuelle est ce qu on pourrait se
retrouver de nouveau avec 15000 morts
oui très probablement si on ne réagit
pas vite dans l'est dans les semaines
qui viennent pour justement créer un
véritable lien entre les systèmes
sanitaires et sociaux de la ville et
l'hôpital et en cas d'attentât chimique
est ce que les hôpitaux sont prêts non
on rallume
gérard darmon on veut des détails
que s'est il passé à cannes mais rien de
rien de très inhabituel quand des gens
de cinéma se rencontrent veulent se
séduire veulent se plaire veulent faire
la fête et veulent vendre leur salade
rien de voilà c'est très agréable comme
c'est sympa formidablement bien joué car
il s'est passé des trucs sexuelles non
[Musique]
donc c'est la même question que c'était
là nous battons ce léger l'incompris
j'aime bien qu'on plus mais je ne sais
pas je ne peux pas vous dire j'étais
dans une autre sphère
alors là pas d'image on rallume fait les
années que je vous attends des années
que je tente cette question
sophie davant
quel temps va-t-il faire demain
c'est de cette façon qu'on m'a jamais
posé merci de me la poser sur sorti
indemne est posée alors sur le nom qu il
va faire beau parce que j'ai mes sources
quand même le faire beau demain soir
juste demain dimanche demain dimanche il
va faire beau à paris merci à tous merci
beaucoup
dominique wolton est ce qu'à votre avis
la télé rend con non absolument pas si
vous voulez c'est les programmes qui
peuvent être con pas le spectateur tout
le problème c'est la responsabilité de
ceux qui font le programme le spectateur
regarde ce qu'on lui offre
et je crois qu'il ya une responsabilité
du récepteur du spectateur bien
évidemment mais si un gars si on regarde
les programmes qu'on la première
responsabilité ceux qui les ont faits
merci on rallume
dr chaussoy vous est il déjà arrivé
depuis de regretter ce geste
non je n'ai jamais regretté parce
qu'encore une fois je pense que c'était
la meilleure solution est là mais la
meilleure la meilleure décision pour
vincent en rallye et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu